quedan menos de 24 horas para que se
produzcan estas elecciones generales en
Turquía unas elecciones cruciales no
solamente para los intereses del país
euroasiático también según los analistas
las elecciones más importantes que se
vayan a producir en este año 2023 en
todo el mundo en estas elecciones el
candidato opositor que mal que estaría
aventajando al candidato gubernamental
por entre 3 y 5 puntos hay algunas
encuestas que incluso le dan la victoria
a que mal que leo en esta primera ronda
es por ello que durante esta semana la
campaña ha estado marcada por los
ataques del bando de resettaigan hacia
la oposición e incluso han recibido
pedradas en algunas en algunos de sus
mítines y actos políticos Eso sí ayer el
presidente ahí ya dijo en una entrevista
que en caso de derrota lo aceptaría sin
ningún problema